[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes là et bravo pour tout ce que
vous faites est juste après pascal le
grand frère épisodes inédits première
épisode sur ces 8 ce sera tout de suite
après et bmp y aura pas de coupure entre
les deux qu'est ce qu'on fait pour moi
une anecdote
alors oui en début d'émission jean luc
m'a dit qu'il avait une anecdote
concernant donc maxime gagné mais juste
avant il ya ya isabelle voulait faire
une blague de pita l'homme lige est une
blague sur le beurre j'ai une blague sur
le beurre est ce que voulait la faire
pour nora l'anecdote
alors allez sur wii c'est ce avec une
pénurie de beurre en ce moment oui oui
donc je me disais tiens c'est moi qui ai
inventé un petit cours mais c'est moi
qui l'inventé ce que vous savez du coup
quelle est la ville de france la plus
recherchée en ce moment c'est petit pour
petits beurre non c'est quoi et la
grande motte alors je peux me retirer
mathieu j'en ai jamais mais
exceptionnellement si vous souhaitez y
en ait allez-y très violent escusez moi
vous croyez que c'est les gros statut
vous nous lancer on échoue à lésigny
alors c'est un escargot qui remonte à
mur est arrivé en haut qui dit j'en ai
bavé ne peut être que mieux
est ce qu est ce que tout le monde a
fait appel à non ce qui s'est passé
parce qu'on se pose plus la question est
ce qu'il ya vraiment quelque chose entre
kelly et et maxime et tout et je pense
que kelly jouer vraiment le jeu et tout
ça mais je me disais que maxine mitrale
partie ce que votre foi je vous assure
que c'est vrai il est parti la loge et
je veux plus qu'il y fait salut nelly
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est que ça avance bien s'établir dans
l'ue que vous avez suivi tout ce qui
s'est passé dans l'émission à votre
façon avec votre oeil qui n'est pas le
nôtre qui est beaucoup plus aiguisé et
vous avez une question d'idées personne
je vous fais exactement qui vous
concernent pas très bien quoi bonjour je
m'appelle joseph j'ai vu que pascal
obispo sentait une comédie musicale sur
jésus donc je voulais savoir s'il y
avait aussi un spectacle en préparation
sur cyril hanouna call fait quand même
plus audience jésus c'est une très bonne
question rosella jeff carr serait que
jésus on entend pas trop venté niveau
axa reim
évidemment que cyril mériterait un
spectacle car c'est quand même un leader
charismatique
un homme qui aura marqué l'histoire
quand même le rappeler jean michel maire
j'en avais la scion cette nuit
vous rêvez de fautes
[Applaudissements]
bon il faudrait qu'il en fait un peu
plus tôt michel savy entre dire des
conneries wifi après c'est vrai qu'il
peut pas s'empêcher d'admirer son patron
regardez même après un zouk approximatif
il vous aime beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jc tout faire mais pour l'instant
malheureusement il n'y a pas de
spectacle prévu pour en hommage à son
oeuvre
on sait juste une chanson ce qui est
déjà pas si mal à carreler quand même
signé calogero 1 vous connaissez non
bien sûr j'adore callovi rond je fais de
la musique
ouais bah oui oui après tout mais moi ça
parle du plaisir de calogero de jouer
des instruments m'inquiète pas du tout
si on écoute bien les paroles il parle
uniquement des chroniqueurs de tmp ce
que c'est vrai soit tu étais pas aperçu
mais mettant des bien l'oreille c'est
saisissant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
obama n'a pas de billet pour le plaisir
mais non mais pour le plaisir
elle entra de rembobiner ces bombes
ainsi
[Musique]
les
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je tiens un truc là je ne sais pas aucun
ogero et tout s'est heureusement mes
félicitations à ceux qui ont d'ailleurs
en parlant de cire et je sais pas ce que
faisait remarquer mais sa passion en ce
moment c'est de tizé ouest par un papa
de picoler d'annoncer quelque chose pour
donner l'envié aux gens de rester ou
revenir après la pub il tisse avec tout
une révélation incroyable à venir vous
invité exceptionnel qui va nous
rejoindre
la semaine dernière il a teasé avec une
vache qui rit et qu'il allait faire
sauter samedi
c'est vrai quand tu fais ça juste avant
la pub ça veut dire que pendant sept
minutes tu vas un fromage collé sur la
main ce qui est un problème pour tout le
monde sauf pour cyril et c'est là on se
dit que le mec est différent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
l'aïe
le mec et en détente le problème c'est
que je vous révèle un secret pendant la
pub normalement six réseaux voix revol
conducteur et discute des dossiers à
traiter dans la suite de l'émission ça
c'est ce qui se passe normalement
mais ce soir là cyril avait une vache
qui rit vous mettiez ça quand je fais un
dos en sa nage tout en déniant j'adore
[Musique]
okeanos
mais n'a pas peur des dossiers pour
salah pour les dossiers que je m'en bats
les couilles des dossiers doit pas que
tu vas pas dessus dans les tâches qui
rit la vache qui rit sont sa voix est
trop occupé pour réfléchir à autre chose
donc la personne qui va parler des
dossiers à l'oreillette a été obligé de
venir voir en plateau bat productrice
agréé at à roullens latorre et la world
de la fille au bout de sa vie est
attribué à
[Musique]
allez-y
[Applaudissements]
fadden avait vu un petit changement
agatha sa maman chérie dix mois dans
l'oreille el mami elle m'a dit je ne te
parle j'adorais oui j'ai vu sa soeur
le teasing ça marche pas toujours et il
est de mon devoir de revenir sur un
épisode douloureux à l'épisode carla du
nom de la nouvelle chroniqueuse de tpm p
ah oui s'il avait tout prévu
vous avez caché tout la journée qu'une
nouvelle qu'on puisse arriver son nom
apparaissait sur aucune feuille de
service
tout ça pour faire un suspens pendant
l'émission ah oui on arrive à la pub on
allait poser quelques questions pour
découvrir son identité et pour être très
honnête à ce moment là tout le monde
autour la table commence à deviner de
qui il s'agissait
mais bon on n'allait pas gâcher le
plaisir de cyril regardez comme ils
avaient l'air heureux où se sont courues
ce qu'ils sont son son papa ouais je
vous dis très très très connu et
j'appellerai en direct parce qu'il n'est
pas du tout mais c'est bien son papa
graphie oui tu as fini et dont
l'émission ce soir action s'ils arrivent
et qui me pète la gueule
eh ben je vous dis non
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
toujours à côte c'est pour ça qu'on
l'ait bonne et ça c'est comme quand tu
fais la queue au cinéma que tu croises
des gens qui sont dans la salle en
disant eh ben tu vois je m'attendais pas
du tout à ce qu'ils meurent la fin des
et moi j'avais envie de moi je suis de
là c'est quand même vous allez voir la
différence entre ce qu'ils avaient
compris qu'il fallait rien dire et il
appelle son son papa ouais je vous dis
très très très connu et j'appellerai en
direct parce qu'il n'est pas du tout au
courant et c'est bien son papa graphie
oui tu as fini et dont l'émission ce
soir par action que les compètes la
gueule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui vous a dit chiche non
franchement isabelle quoi ne changeait
pas ah non mais vraiment voilà parce que
sinon on n'aurait pas eu cette séquence
pour écouter adoré l'autre derrière et
qui doit retenir la pch ça va ma chérie
mais oui voilà partis et c'est parce que
je dessine donc tout d'un coup je vais
regarder mais ressemble à la vie de
diana c'est comme ça que allez on
continue notre est-ce que vous a déjà
dit qu'elle était portraitiste va
sûrement là ni eau
d'accord elle le dit tout les tous les
jours quand elle est et il est temps de
passer à tous qu'on va pas voulu voir ou
entendre cette semaine et on commence
par rachid arhab qui se pose plein de
questions sur cyril et rachid qui a
toujours le petit mot qui fait du bien
pour les invités si tu mets rachid aux
standards de sos détresse amitié
je pense qu'ils ferment boutique en 48
heures je regrette pas réellement je
regrette juste de la manière que j'ai
fait que je me suis perdue en année
alors je vais vous dire sachez que les
gens oublient très vite ou deux dans un
an ou deux ans tondre oblique vous avez
fait les marchés ni les images restent
quand même
après je comprends pas pourquoi vous
danser tout le temps il ya des voies de
fait et je me demande s'il voulait
préparer vous étiez là mes 40 ans je
sais je suis toujours là pour les
grandes occasions
alors là c'est raté
[Musique]
moi jamais
alors certes de temps bien celui ci
prend le pas sur le jeu chante tellement
bien leur train de comprendre le système
nous disent oui comment tout ça va toi
tu es bien haut les monnaies calcul
la plupart d'entre eux n'ont jamais
connu cette méthode
quant à côté ses généraux et achèteront
face mais associe ses s'apprête
aujourd'hui à aujourd'hui c'est votre
feuilleton sur la terre alors n'attendez
pas trop masculin alors j'aurais parlé
un peu réalisation maintenant est ce que
vous savez ce que c'est un split screen
cyril c'est quand on coupe les images en
deux voilà c'est quand l'écran est
coupée en plusieurs parties pour montrer
en même temps deux personnes qui se
parlent oui ça se fait quand les
personnes sont géographiquement loin de
l'autrui c'est vrai sauf dans tpm p
voici certainement le split-screen le
plus inutile de l'histoire de la
télévision
ces mots nous rejoigne il yad'autres
chaussée les quatre tirs de jean luc
lemoine comme tous les mercredis avec
c'est un génie celui-ci alors si l'on
laisse les nains alors soit cinéma des
boîtes de 10 mètres de long si on était
vraiment l'un à côté de l'autre
la semaine dernière nous recevrons live
offenbach ah oui malheureusement
jean-michel s'était pas jacques
offenbach le compositeur mais offenbach
le duo de musique électronique créée si
malheureusement parce que sans vouloir
m'avancer vu ses règles son pendant le
live
je pense pas que jean-michel ira les
voir en concert chez parce qu'il avait
ici était fatigué de cette crise était
de réveiller un peu trop tôt à un vers
15 heures mais là c'était l'orage de la
semaine c'est énorme
[Musique]
je vais
gt rien
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon là quelques chauffeurs de
salle et offenbach catchy c'est déjà
numéro un les gars je vous dis tout de
suite
ces décès d'annie énorme narrateur est
un garage est bon non mais vous
connaissez pas encore mais ça non ce
qu'ils font mais toi tu aimes vraiment
pas vite assez énorme ce qu'il faut
faire
moi j'aime bien mais en fait on peut ne
pas aimer mais les durs quand même à
dire que la bri à bâle
non je suis vieux non mais je crois que
c'est ça les grilles il deviendrait même
moi je connais ah oui je m'étais
beaucoup plus jeunes un joker et tirait
nantaise beaucoup pas pareil
vous adorez fait bac oui la chanson
notamment qu'on a entendu là chaque jour
c'est si long et si vous connaissez
quels autres chansons d'offenbach je
connais jamais les rideaux ne joue pas
la jeune tu connais pas et y en a qui
jouent aux jeunes c'est pas moi
[Applaudissements]
des couleurs et j'ai repéré quelques
petits degrés sur le côté wallon pardon
c'était les volets allait repartir sur
de meilleurs sentiments
alors beaucoup de gens m'ont écrit pour
me dire qu'ils avaient aimé la semaine
dernière la séquence du fou rire de
benjamin castaldi ce moment étrange où
benjamin n'avait plus de dieu si ses
paupières diot et ses paupières du bas
vous laisse faire des bisous vous avez
la chance car il faut savoir qu'une
semaine s'en fou rire est une semaine
perdue pour benji ya deux choses qu'il
faut partir à coup sûr gagnant de secret
story et ça mais non mais non mais non
je vais très bien la [ __ ] il à thème
sa gamine qui existe à son excellent
batteur oh merde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est-ce que revoir la tête d'agathe et la
tête de rachida bonjour on est en effet
dans les vagues à aller au bout de sa
vie est encore gérable et il faut qu'il
y ait un gain est allé au bout de sa
défense ont déconné oui on peut revoir
ça tu as toujours voulu regarder
regardez la tête et pour finir passons
au top gênant ces petits moments un
impeccable qui se passe que dans touche
pas à mon poste mais bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sachez que le nouveau gars on a fait un
énorme carton d'audience
[Musique]
il a fait des compliments sur ma vie
entre amis
[Musique]
d'accord jeu du pendu
ça vous concerne vous qui commence par
ça
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]